Eustace grew up in the suburbs in North Carolina. He watched TV, ate candy, rode a bike, all pretty much like any suburban kid, until, at the age of 17, he moved out in the woods and never came back.
尤斯塔斯在北卡罗来纳州的郊区长大。他看电视、吃糖果、骑自行车，和所有郊区的孩子没什么两样。直到17岁那年，他搬进了树林，就再也没回来。
I had moved out into the forest. I was 17 years old, and I just decided that I would try an alternative style of living. And really, with that, I didn't think it all through in a major, complex way. I just decided I would like to try living outside. And so I moved out and started camping in a tepee, hunting and gathering food and making my own tools and clothes.
我搬到了森林里。那时我17岁，我决定尝试一种非主流的生活方式。说实话，我并没有经过什么深思熟虑或复杂的考量，只是单纯觉得想尝试在大自然中生活。于是我搬了出去，开始住帐篷，靠打猎采集为生，自己制作工具和衣服。
And let me just be sure people understand. When you're living outside, you were there year round.
让我确认一下，大家都明白吗？当你住在户外时，你是全年都在那里住的。
Yeah, totally moved out. In fact, I've lived outside for 20 years now.
是的，完全搬出去了。事实上，我已经在户外生活了20年。
From the time Eustace moved outside, he was interested in the past and all the things that people knew about how to live with nature, back when they had no choice about living with nature. For years, he lived in the woods, slept in a tepee, hunted his own food with bow and arrow, made his own clothes out of deerskin, his own utensils and tools.
自从尤斯塔斯搬到户外，他就对过去以及人们如何在自然中生存产生了浓厚兴趣，回到那种别无选择只能与自然共处的时代。多年来，他住在树林里，睡在帐篷里，用弓箭猎取食物，用鹿皮制作衣物，并亲手打造自己的餐具和工具。
And then he started to evolve from a life as a hunter-gatherer to basic agriculture. He learned to plant and harvest, cultivated a patch of land, started raising animals, taught himself how to work with horses and mules. In other words, he personally went to through the major evolutionary stages that took the human species about 10,000 years during the Late Cenozoic. And around the same time he moved out into the forest, he had another idea, to ride a horse across America.
后来，他的生活方式从狩猎采集演变为基础农业。他学会了耕种和收获，开垦了一片土地，开始饲养动物，自学如何驯养马匹和骡子。换句话说，他亲身经历了人类在新生代晚期耗时约一万年才完成的主要进化阶段。大约在他搬到森林的同时，他又产生了一个想法：骑马横穿美国。
And I decided to do it when I was sitting around a campfire. And I heard about a couple that was living with their horses in the national forest. And it just sort of struck me. It was like a thunderbolt. It's like it came into my mind and I said-- it's like I didn't even know what was coming out of my mouth. I just said, I'm going to ride a horse across America someday.
那是坐在篝火旁时决定的。我听说有一对夫妇带着他们的马住在国家森林里。那个想法就像闪电一样击中了我，灵光一闪，它突然出现在脑海里，我说——我甚至不知道自己说了什么，我只是说：“总有一天，我要骑马横穿美国。”
And then he asked me if I wanted to go.
然后他问我愿不愿意一起去。
Eustace's younger brother, Judson.
尤斯塔斯的弟弟，贾德森。
And my first reaction was, well, no, not really.
我最初的反应是，嗯，不了，不太想去。
Why?
为什么？
It just seemed like a big undertaking, and I was happy in my little life. But then, I looked and I asked myself, well, what reason do you not have to go? Why shouldn't you go? Why not? And one of my biggest inspirations for going was to spend time with him.
这听起来是一项巨大的工程，而且我对自己的小日子感到很满足。但后来，我看着自己，问自己：你有什么不去的原因吗？为什么你不该去？为什么不呢？我决定去的一个最大动力就是想和他多待在一起。
Yeah?
是吗？
17 years after he first decided to ride across America, Eustace finally set out on the trail with his brother. The ride was partly an experiment in time travel. What happens when you try to live how people lived over a century ago? It was partly a lark, an adventure. Men on horses battling the elements, testing themselves, launched toward a goal they had no idea if they could reach.
在决定骑马横穿美国17年后，尤斯塔斯终于带着他的弟弟踏上了旅程。这次骑行在某种程度上是一次时间旅行的实验。如果你尝试像一个世纪前的人那样生活，会发生什么？这既是一次恶作剧，也是一次冒险。骑马的人对抗着大自然的风暴，考验着自己，向着一个他们完全不知道能否实现的目标进发。
But I should tell you that for Eustace, the main idea behind this trip was not nearly so grand as all that. For Eustace, a big part of it was simply about horses. Eustace had been working with horses for a while when he sat out on the trail, but he knew there was just something about living with horses, working with horses, that he was going to learn if he rode so long, so steadily for months.
但我必须告诉你，对尤斯塔斯来说，这次旅行背后的初衷远没有那么宏大。对尤斯塔斯而言，其中很大一部分原因仅仅是关于马。尤斯塔斯在踏上旅途时已经与马相处了一段时间，但他知道，只要骑马骑得足够久、足够稳定，历时数月，他一定能学到一些关于与马共处、与马协作的真谛。
He took Judson, who had worked with horses on a ranch in Wyoming, he was a wrangler, took people on trips into the wilderness, plus an acquaintance of theirs, Susan Klimkowski, who worked for a couple years in a stable, had a horse of her own. There are indoor people and there are outdoor people. Susan grew up down the street from Eustace and Judson, three kids who spent a lot of time out of doors.
他带上了贾德森，贾德森曾在怀俄明州的牧场工作，是个牧马人，带过人进入荒野旅行；此外还有他们的熟人苏珊·克林科夫斯基，她在马厩工作过几年，自己也有一匹马。人分为室内型和户外型。苏珊和尤斯塔斯、贾德森住同一条街，他们三个孩子小时候都花了很多时间在户外。
I grew up in a neighborhood where us kids, we all hung out and liked to run up and down the creek chasing crawdads and fish and snakes and turtles, but we lived in town.
我在一个街区长大，我们那帮孩子总是在一起玩，喜欢沿着小溪跑来跑去，追逐小龙虾、鱼、蛇和乌龟，但我们住在镇上。
When you look around, do you feel like most people are indoors people or most people are outdoors people that you meet?
环顾四周，你觉得你遇到的大多数人是室内型还是户外型？
Most people are indoors people, but I think they want to be outdoor. But they don't know how to get outside and enjoy it.
大多数人是室内型，但我认为他们内心渴望成为户外型。只是他们不知道该如何走出户外并享受它。
They set out on Christmas Day 1995 from a beach in South Carolina. They carried a cassette tape recorder with them to keep a kind of audio journal of their trip. And it's those tapes that make up a lot of our show today.
1995年圣诞节，他们从南卡罗来纳州的一片海滩出发。他们带着一台卡式录音机，为他们的旅行写一种音频日记。正是这些录音带构成了我们今天节目的大部分内容。
So to make this history for the recorder, tell us who you are and what you're about.
为了给录音留下这段历史，请告诉我们你是谁，以及你的背景。
I'm David Elliott. I'm the priest here at Holy Trinity Episcopal Church. And I'll go out and bless the trip in a few minutes. I envy you. I think it'll be wonderful. Responsibilities tie me down. They tie everybody down.
我是大卫·艾略特。我是圣三一圣公会的牧师。几分钟后我会出去为这次旅行祈福。我很羡慕你们。我想这会非常美妙。责任束缚着我。它们束缚着每一个人。
Let us pray. Dear God, our heavenly father, we give you thanks this day for the beauty of your creation. We give you thanks also for the human spirit. Guide these people on their trip all the way to California. Guide them safely, dear God. All this we ask in Christ's name. Amen.
让我们祈祷。亲爱的上帝，我们的天父，我们感谢您赐予今天这造物的美丽。我们也感谢您赐予人类的精神。指引这些人完成全程直到加州。引导他们平安，亲爱的上帝。这一切我们奉基督之名祈求。阿门。
[OTHERS SAY AMEN]
[其他人齐声说阿门]
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio international, it's This . American . Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Adventures in the Simple Life.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，节目是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是《简单生活的冒险》。
Act One, Long Riders. What you learn and what you find when you head out in the dead of winter, near the end of the 20th century, in a completely industrialized country, on a 2,500 mile horse trip.
第一幕，长途骑行者。当你身处20世纪末的隆冬，在一个完全工业化的国家，进行一场2500英里的骑马之旅时，你会学到什么，又会发现什么。
Act Two, Zen Shmen. What happens when your best friend renounces everything the two of you share, everything about your lives, to go live a simpler life in the mountains in a monastery? Stay with us.
第二幕，禅宗什么的。当你的好友抛弃了你们共享的一切，抛弃了你们生活中的一切，去山里的寺院过一种更简单的生活时，会发生什么？请继续收听。
Act One, Long Riders. So when they set out, it was Eustace, Judson and Susan, four horses, one was a spare, camping gear, and a truck. And it's kind of a crazy scheme the way that they worked the whole thing. Every day, they would wake up, and then one of the would drive the truck 20 or 30 miles ahead to wherever it was they were going to camp the next night. And then that person would have to hitchhike back the same 20 or 30 miles, which could take hours.
第一幕，长途骑行者。他们出发时，尤斯塔斯、贾德森和苏珊带着四匹马（其中一匹是备用的）、露营装备和一辆卡车。他们运作整个事情的方式有点疯狂。每天，他们醒来后，其中一个人会开车把卡车提前开到20或30英里外他们第二天晚上露营的地方。然后那个人必须搭车返回这20到30英里，这可能需要几个小时。
And then, after that, they would set out on their horses and they would ride all day. A couple months into the trip, they had this guy named Walker Young who joined the team to drive the truck ahead and find places to camp and handle stuff like that. The other crazy 20th century adaptation to their 19th century horse ride is it they did not ride through open country. They trotted along on the shoulders of highways, on the sides of roads. It seemed like the most efficient route.
之后，他们会骑马出发，整天都在路上骑行。旅行进行了几个月后，有一个叫沃克·杨的人加入了团队，负责提前开卡车、找露营地以及处理类似的事情。他们那场19世纪骑马之旅在20世纪的另一个疯狂调整是，他们并没有骑行穿越开阔的乡野。他们沿着高速公路的路肩和道路一侧慢跑。这似乎是最有效的路线。
You recorded yourselves as you rode across the country on a cassette machine, about 30 hours of tape, starting with that first day. Can I ask you what it was like setting out?
你们在骑马横穿全国时用卡式磁带机录下了自己的声音，大约30小时的录音，从第一天开始。我能问问出发时是什么感觉吗？
Oh, it was easy setting out. It was sort of like, OK, the day has come. We're going. I knew that we didn't know what we were doing. That was OK. I was real satisfied with that. I personally knew that there was a big chance that we wouldn't make it. My partners were a little bit younger and had done less traveling, a little bit more idealistic. And so they were Gung ho. Yeah, we're going to do this thing. We're going to make it.
哦，出发时很轻松。感觉就像，好吧，日子到了。我们要走了。我知道我们不知道自己在做什么。但那没关系。对此我真的很满足。我个人知道，我们有很大的可能无法成功。我的同伴比我年轻一点，旅行经验较少，更理想主义一些。所以他们非常热衷。“是的，我们要做到这一点。我们会成功的。”
That sound in the background is the defroster. This is Eustace Conway on the 25th of December. Sitting beside me-- oh, you hear that little yelp? Let me hear that yelp again.
背景里的那个声音是除霜器。今天是12月25日，我是尤斯塔斯·康威。坐在我身边的是——哦，你听到那个小小的尖叫了吗？让我再听一遍那个尖叫。
[YELPS]
[尖叫声]
That was a big yelp. That's Judson Conway. He's a crazy. And then between us is the lovely lady. What's your name?
那是个大尖叫。那是贾德森·康威。他是个疯子。在我们中间的是可爱的女士。你叫什么名字？
Susan.
苏珊。
Susan what?
苏珊什么？
Klimkowski.
克林科夫斯基。
She's a simple lady.
她是一位朴实的女士。
In that first day, I have to say you all sound so young and happy.
在第一天，我不得不说你们听起来都那么年轻快乐。
We were. Yeah.
我们确实是。是的。
Trotting along, trotting along, trotting along. Beautiful pink clouds above our head, baby blue background, the pines are dark getting black in the bottom. It's hard to trot when you're halfway twisted around looking at the beauty of it. Man, what a day. Mmm.
小跑着，小跑着，小跑着。头顶上是美丽的粉红色云彩，背景是淡蓝色，松树在底部显得深暗，甚至发黑。当你半转过身看着这美景时，很难保持小跑。天哪，多么美好的一天。嗯。
I feel fully alive, fully awake. It's sacred, this minute of living, of passion, with dream. I hear that Pileated Woodpecker in the background. I hear a car coming up behind me. Just a little bit further, we'll be off the bridge.
我觉得完全活着，完全清醒。这一刻的生活、激情和梦想是神圣的。我听到了背景里啄木鸟的声音。我听到后面有车跟上来。再走一点，我们就离开桥了。
We knew almost nothing about this. We didn't know what we were doing. Even finding a route, like how were we going to go across.
我们对此几乎一无所知。我们不知道自己在做什么。甚至连路线怎么走，怎么横穿全国都不知道。
Did you have a big atlas or something?
你们有大型地图集之类的吗？
We had a few state road maps. A few state road maps is all we had to go by. And everybody kept saying, well, what's your route? How are you going to go? And I was like, I don't really know. We're heading west every day.
我们只有几张州公路地图。我们只有几张州地图可以参考。每个人都不断问：“那么，你们的路线是什么？你们打算怎么走？”我回答：“我真的不知道。我们每天都在向西走。”
It's 7:00 in the morning. This'll be our third day. It's about light enough to see out here, and the horses look well. Been going over for the last hour what we're going to do today. I think we'll drive the truck forward to highway 32.
现在是早上7点。这将是我们第三天。外面光线足够看清了，马看起来状态不错。过去一小时里我们一直在讨论今天要做什么。我想我们会把卡车开到32号公路。
Well, it's 9 o'clock, and we're riding along. We stayed at Walter Hodges', and Clara Belle, their monkey, entertained us a little bit. They've had their monkey for years. And he told us about how one time, she had gotten electrocuted by climbing up on some wires. And she was getting shocked, and it had been raining a little bit.
好吧，现在是9点，我们正在骑行。我们住在沃尔特·霍奇斯家，他们的猴子克拉拉·贝尔逗乐了我们一下。他们养那只猴子好多年了。他告诉我们有一次，她因为爬上电线触电了。她被电击了，而且当时还下着点雨。
So he backed his track up and got a broom-- a dry broom-- and knocked Clara Belle off. And she was stunned on the ground. And then later in the evening, he said, what do you think about the monkey? And they had referred to it as their daughter. I said, well, I don't know. I think it's kind of strange somebody keeps their daughter tied up in the backyard and gives her electrical shock treatments and then beats her with a broom. I guess you had to be there.
于是他把卡车倒过去，拿了一把扫帚——一把干扫帚——把克拉拉·贝尔扫了下来。她在地上被电晕了。后来晚上，他问：“你们觉得这只猴子怎么样？”他们把那只猴子当成自己的女儿。我说：“嗯，我不知道。我觉得有人把自己的女儿绑在后院，给她电击治疗，然后用扫帚打她，这有点奇怪。”我想你得身临其境才能体会。
We're getting our first rain right now, the first rain of the whole trip. It's drizzling. Not much of a rain, but enough to lower our spirits enough to worry.
我们现在遇到了第一场雨，整个旅程的第一场雨。下着毛毛雨。雨不大，但足以让我们情绪低落，感到担忧。
Hey.
嘿。
Hey, no.
嘿，不。
Not my spirit, bro.
不是我的情绪，伙计。
You're over here whining.
你在那边发牢骚。
No, you were the one whining.
不，发牢骚的是你。
"I wish it would stop raining until we got to camp."
“我希望在到达营地之前雨能停。”
And describe how you were all outfitted. What did you all look like?
说说你们是怎么装备自己的。你们看起来是什么样子？
We were basically wearing a lot of the Western-style clothes, which wasn't for style but all these old cowboy clothes, they actually work. They do the things that you need. Silk scarves, cowboy hats.
我们基本上穿着很多西部风格的衣服，这不是为了时尚，而是因为这些老式牛仔服装确实实用。它们能完成你需要的功能。丝巾、牛仔帽。
The chaps and the spurs and the whole bit.
皮套裤、马刺，全套装备。
--had guns and knives and long hair and looked rough as hell and all kinds of stories, interesting reactions coming out of that. Well, here's a good description. Here's a story. We're trotting through this little town and going down Main Street, and I see someone through a plate glass window look at us. And they're sort of awed. The mouth drops open, it's like, my gosh, what's going on here?
——带着枪和刀，留着长发，看起来狂野得要命，还有各种各样的故事，产生了很多有趣的反应。嗯，这儿有个很好的描述。这有个故事。我们正小跑着穿过一个小镇，沿着主街走，我看到有人透过平板玻璃窗看着我们。他们显得很敬畏。嘴巴张开了，就像是，“天哪，发生了什么？”
So I see the man just grab something from his desk and run out the front door. So I look back every once in a while, and this guy is sort of half-running behind us. Finally, we get to the edge of town. It's misting, a bit rainy. And he says, "Hey, I didn't want to interrupt you. I thought you might be making a movie or something." It's like, "No, we're not making a movie."
于是我看到那个男人抓起桌上的东西，跑出门外。我时不时回头看，那个家伙就在我们后面半跑着。终于，我们到了镇边。天气有点阴，下着小雨。他说：“嘿，我不想打扰你们。我还以为你们在拍电影什么的。”我说：“不，我们没在拍电影。”
And he says, "But you guys look so real. I mean, you really look real." And I was like, "Well, I think that probably is because we really are real." And he said this over and another. It was like he was stuttering this chant, like, "You guys look real. I mean, you really look real."
他说：“但你们看起来太真实了。我是说，你们看起来真的太真实了。”我就说：“嗯，我想那可能是因为我们确实很真实。”他一遍又一遍地重复。就像在结结巴巴地念咒语一样：“你们看起来很真实。我是说，你们真的看起来很真实。”
And now-- I'm glad the tape recorder's working-- now Judson's going to fire off a round to celebrate making it across a whole state in the Southeast Georgia. We just entered Alabama. Do it, brother!
现在——我很高兴录音机在工作——现在贾德森要放一枪来庆祝我们横穿了乔治亚州东部。我们刚进入阿拉巴马州。开火吧，兄弟！
[FIRES GUN]
[枪声]
Whew! Oh, my god.
呼！哦，天哪。
Let me ask you to talk about some of the people you met along the way.
让我请你谈谈沿途遇到的一些人。
Uh huh. Where would I begin? That's the most amazing part of the entire journey.
嗯。我从哪里开始呢？那是整个旅程中最令人惊奇的部分。
People would really appreciate and take us in in ways that I never imagined would be possible. You know, these odd-looking rogues with long hair, knives and guns, and yet, the most conservative, Southern, clean-cut gentleman, farmers, would bring us right into their homes with their children, their wives, and just treat us like we were part of the family.
人们以我从未想过可能的方式真正欣赏并接纳我们。你知道，这些留着长发、带着刀枪、看起来古怪的流浪汉，然而，那些最保守、最南方的、衣着整洁的绅士、农民们，竟然会把我们带进他们的家里，和他们的孩子、妻子在一起，就像对待家人一样对待我们。
The entire America was great. They were most gracious and accepted us. And we'd go into one town and they'd say, oh, watch out for this next town that you're going through because they're kind of questionable people. And we'd get to that town and they'd be just as nice as the last one. Everybody was great.
整个美国都很棒。他们最亲切，接纳了我们。我们进一个镇，他们会说：“哦，小心下一个镇，因为那里的人有点成问题。”结果我们到了那个镇，他们和上一个镇的人一样好。每个人都很好。
Long story. I don't know how much you want to tape. But let's just say one morning, I met these two guys. I was actually standing on the side of the road with a fan of money trying to get a ride. And they pull up to buy some beer, Sunday morning, actually.
这是一个很长的故事。我不知道你想录多少。但我们就说，一天早上，我遇到了这两个家伙。我当时站在路边拿着一叠钱想搭车。他们开车过来买啤酒，其实是周日早上。
On their way to church.
在他们去教堂的路上。
Yeah. So this sporty little car pulls up with shiny mag wheels and comes to a stop right there at the quick stop across the road. And one of them goes in there to get something. I haven't met them at this time. So I'm out there, and I kind of smile, hold my money up. And so apparently, J.L. was in the driver seat at this time. And he leans out of the car door and says, "Hey, you got any money?" And so I'm embarrassed. I look around, I went, "Yes."
是的。那辆运动型小车停在路对面的快速便利店那里。其中一个人进去买东西。我当时还没见过他们。我站在外面，笑着，举着钱。显然，J.L.当时坐在驾驶座上。他探出车门说：“嘿，你有钱吗？”我感到很尴尬。我环顾四周，说：“有的。”
"I say, you got any money?" And I think I better go negotiate with this man before I alarm the whole neighborhood. So I told him I'd give him $5 just to get me to the other side of the town. Actually, I'd gotten a ride halfway already. So I was trying just to get on the other side of town. So we're sitting there negotiating back and forth and back and forth. And Tyrone comes walking out. these two guys are buddies, J.L. and Tyrone. Tyrone comes walking out with this beer. And he just looks at me, he says, "You want a ride?"
“我说，你有钱吗？”我想在惊动全社区之前，最好先跟这个人谈谈。所以我告诉他，只要能把我送到镇的另一头，我就给他5美元。其实，我已经搭了一半路了。所以我只是想去镇的另一头。我们坐在那儿谈来谈去，谈来谈去。然后泰隆走出来了。这两个家伙是哥们，J.L.和泰隆。泰隆拿着啤酒走出来。他看着我说：“你想搭车吗？”
And I said, "Yeah." He says, "Get in the truck." So apparently, it was Tyrone's truck. So they crank it up and they start going along. And Tyrone pulls out a beer from his six pack. And he grabs that and he opens it. You can see the mist coming out. And he just looks at it, and he smells it, and he's just about to take a swig. He's reverently getting ready to drink his beer.
我说：“想。”他说：“上车。”显然那是泰隆的车。他们发动车子开始走了。泰隆从六罐装里拿出一瓶啤酒。他抓起它打开。你可以看到雾气飘出来。他看着它，闻了闻，正准备喝上一口。他虔诚地准备喝他的啤酒。
And he's just about to turn it back and drink, and he looks to me. All of a sudden, he remembers his manners. He's like, "You like beer?" I say, "Uh huh." "You want a beer?" Being polite, I say, "Well, sure, OK." So he gives me a beer. Then he cracks another one for himself. He says, "I like beer. I love beer. I'll drink beer every day." So then he takes this big morning drink. It's like, whoa, this guy is into his beer.
他正要仰头喝的时候，看了我一眼。突然间，他记起了他的礼貌。他说：“你喜欢喝啤酒吗？”我说：“嗯。”“你想喝吗？”出于礼貌，我说：“嗯，当然，好啊。”于是他给了我一瓶啤酒。然后他又为自己开了一瓶。他说：“我喜欢啤酒。我爱啤酒。我每天都要喝啤酒。”然后他大口喝了一口。就像，哇，这家伙真是个啤酒迷。
So I'm sitting there talking to J.L., hanging through the truck window. And he's telling me about his life. So he'll tell me something, and then I'll tell him something. I'm telling him about the Long Riders journey. And I'm telling him about the horses. Yeah, we got horses waiting over there. He's listening. At this time, I had no idea. But he thought I was full of [BLEEP]. He thought I was tripping on acid and had no idea that anything I was saying made any sense.
我坐在那儿和趴在车窗上的J.L.聊天。他告诉我他的生活。他告诉我一些事，我就告诉他一些事。我告诉他关于“长途骑行者”的旅程。我告诉他关于马的事。是的，我们的马在那边等着。他在听。当时，我完全不知道。但他以为我在胡扯。他以为我吸毒了，根本没觉得我说的任何话有道理。
So we're having this conversation. And I think he's believing everything, so I'm telling him about my life, my story.
我们正聊着。我想他肯定信了，所以我告诉他我的生活，我的故事。
You're telling him your life, so you're telling him, "I live in the woods. I've lived there since I was a teenager. I trap my own animals." And he's just thinking, yeah right.
你在告诉他你的生活，告诉他：“我住在树林里。我从青少年时期就住在那里。我捕捉自己的动物。”他只是在想，是啊，没错。
You got it. You got the picture. So we get to the gas station. I fill them up with gas. Then we drive on. And so we come around the bend. He starts wondering if I even know where I want to go, like, if I'm just crazy.
对了。你理解了。我们到了加油站。我给他们加满了油。然后我们继续开。我们转过弯。他开始怀疑我是不是真的知道自己想去哪，就像，我是不是个疯子。
Making the whole thing up. Right.
全是编出来的。没错。
So we round the bend, and there is my partners with the horses. And J.L. is like, "[BLEEP], man, they got horses! They got horses!" He is just absolutely amazed. He throws the car into park and jumps out, leaves the door wide open, and just runs over to the horses and reaches out to touch them, as if, can they be real?
我们转过弯，我的同伴和马就在那里。J.L.就像，“天哪，伙计，他们有马！他们真的有马！”他简直太震惊了。他把车挂入停车档跳出来，车门敞开着，直接跑向马匹，伸出手去触摸它们，好像在问，它们是真的吗？
All of a sudden, everything shifts. Instead of being a freak, all of a sudden, he's got respect for me, and the reality comes in. And he wants to help out. Instead of trying to take my money-- here's how I met this guy. "You got any money?" He's trying hard as he can to take me for any kind of dollar bill. And all of a sudden, heart comes in. Feeling. Something totally shifts. And he cares about us. And so he comes out and meets us on the road several times, brings a friend. They drive the truck ahead a couple of days. And just such a shift from our introduction.
突然间，一切都变了。与其说我是个怪胎，突然间，他对我产生了尊重，现实感进来了。他想帮忙。与其试图拿走我的钱——这就是我遇到这家伙的方式。“你有钱吗？”他费尽心思想骗我的任何一张美元纸币。突然间，爱心进来了。感觉。有什么东西完全改变了。他关心我们。他后来又在路上遇到了我们好几次，还带了个朋友。他们甚至提前开了几天卡车。和我们初见时简直是天壤之别。
When they'd ride into town, they'd try to find somebody with a fenced-in field or yard, and they would ask them if they could camp there. And over and over, people not only said yes, they invited them in for hot meals and hot showers, helped them out any way they could. There was this one family in Louisiana, the Marbles, who, after putting up Eustace and Judson and Susan for days, really, helping them find a new horse, decided to deliver them a hot turkey meal with stuffing and cranberry dressing and all the fixings out on the road.
当他们骑马进入小镇时，他们会试着找一个有围栏的场地或院子，问房主能否在那里露营。一次又一次，人们不仅答应了，还邀请他们吃热饭、洗热水澡，尽一切可能帮助他们。在路易斯安那州有一个大理石家庭，在招待了尤斯塔斯、贾德森和苏珊几天，真正帮助他们找到一匹新马后，决定在路上给他们送去一份火鸡热餐，配上填料、蔓越莓酱和所有配菜。
We were riding down the road several hundred miles from where they live. And all of a sudden, they drive by hooting and hollering out the window. My gosh, is that the Marbles? And they pulled over ahead of us and by the time we got to them, they had a big old Thanksgiving dinner is what I called it, even though it was January or February.
我们正沿着路骑行，距离他们住的地方有几百英里。突然间，他们一边按喇叭一边在窗外大喊大叫。天哪，那是大理石一家吗？他们在我们前面靠边停车，当我们赶到时，他们准备了一顿盛大的感恩节晚餐，尽管当时是1月或2月。
And they had driven hundreds of miles?
他们开了几百英里？
Yeah, and they had no idea exactly where we were. They was just in a hope that they could find us. All the cooking, all the driving, all the planning to have that Sunday afternoon to come try to find us. And they did.
是的，他们根本不知道我们到底在哪里。他们只是希望能找到我们。所有的烹饪，所有的驾驶，所有的计划，就为了那个周日下午来试着找到我们。他们真的做到了。
Judson, why do you think people were responding the way they were to the three of you traveling?
贾德森，你认为为什么人们会对你们三人的旅行做出这样的反应？
Because we were doing something that everybody dreams about but nobody takes the risk to do-- or the time, the energy, the money, the challenge to do.
因为我们正在做每个人都梦想但没人敢去冒险做的事情——或者没时间、没精力、没钱、没勇气去挑战。
I guess I have my own way of thinking about it, is I wanted to tell people you can do whatever you want. Celebrate life. Don't just work at a grind forever. Just stop. Just say, "I want to do this. That's what I did. I said I want to ride a horse across the country. I had a thousand people tell me I couldn't. I didn't listen to one of them. I said, I'm going to do this. And I got on a horse and started out. I didn't know how to do this journey. I didn't know much about riding horses.
我想我有我自己的想法，我是想告诉人们你可以做任何你想做的事。庆祝生活。不要只是永远在工作中磨损。停下来。只要说：“我想做这个。”这就是我做的。我说我想骑马横穿全国。有一千个人告诉我我做不到。我一个都没听。我说：“我要做这个。”我骑上一匹马就开始了。我不知道怎么完成这个旅程。我对骑马知之甚少。
It sounds like the three of you are just out there just like putting your hearts out there. You know what I mean? Just doing this thing. And so that just calls this thing forward from other people where they want to do it too.
听起来你们三个就像是把自己的心掏出来放在外面。你知道我的意思吗？只是在做这件事。所以这激发了其他人内心深处的某些东西，让他们也想去做。
It does. People would even just ride up and roll down their window and stick out a $10 bill.
确实。人们甚至会直接骑车过来，摇下车窗，递出一张10美元的钞票。
Several times, we would turn people down. People were like, "Let me help you. You can stay at our house." And we're like, "Well, we've already got plans. Somebody already pulled over and invited us to stay their house." And several times, we split up, and one of us would spend the night one place and somebody else would spend the night somewhere else.
好几次，我们拒绝了别人。人们说：“让我帮你吧。你可以住在我家。”我们说：“嗯，我们已经有计划了。已经有人靠边停车邀请我们住他们家了。”好几次，我们分开了，一个人在别处过夜，其他人也在别处过夜。
Part of this reaction had to do with the horses, Eustace and Judson say. They had both hitchhiked across America, and they say that people are not nearly so friendly. But with the horses, they would ride into town, looking like cowboys, charming and dusty, like figures not just out of a the movie but out of some dream that we all have of America.
尤斯塔斯和贾德森说，这种反应的一部分与马有关。他们俩都曾经搭车横穿美国，他们说人们根本没那么友好。但有了马，他们骑马进入小镇时，看起来像牛仔，迷人又充满尘土，就像从电影中走出来，更是从我们所有人关于美国的梦中走出来的形象。
When these epic figures trot up the interstate into your town, how could you not stare? Who would not want to be near something so larger than life. People didn't just give them money. People wanted to talk to them, tell them their stories, which Eustace recorded on tape.
当这些史诗般的形象慢跑着进入你的小镇时，你怎么能不盯着看？谁不想靠近这种超越生活的东西呢？人们不只是给他们钱。人们想和他们交谈，讲述他们的故事，尤斯塔斯把这些都录在了磁带上。
Allison, tell our diary what's going on. What do you do for a living? Where are we? And anything you want to say?
艾利森，告诉我们的日记发生了什么。你的工作是什么？我们在哪儿？任何你想说的话？
We're at a rock shop out in the middle of nowhere. In fact, we're three miles from the middle of nowhere. Mile marker 33 is the middle. We just kind of poke along out here. And this used to be owned by Sam and Vera Jones.
我们在荒郊野外的一家石头店。事实上，我们距离荒郊野外还有三英里。33号里程碑就是中间点。我们就在这里瞎晃。这里以前是萨姆和维拉·琼斯拥有的。
Sam was otherwise known as Rattlesnake Jones. He believed in protecting rattlesnakes. He had a rattlesnake pit out here with over 200 rattlesnakes in it at all times. Him and Vera also had two pet bobcats. And a lot of neat history out here.
萨姆又名“响尾蛇琼斯”。他相信保护响尾蛇。他在这里有一个响尾蛇坑，里面随时都有200多条响尾蛇。他和维拉还有两只宠物短尾猫。这里有很多有趣的往事。
Sam killed himself on the front doorstep over there of the trailer because he was dying of cancer and all sorts of health problems. He was living on a hospital bed on an oxygen tank. And he told his wife that he was going shoot himself that morning. And she said as long as he didn't do it inside the house. She didn't want to clean up the mess. And she knew he was serious. And she was out in the rock shop and heard the gunshot and waited about an hour before she called the ambulance because he didn't want to be resuscitated. He wanted to be dead.
萨姆在外面拖车的前门廊上自杀了，因为他患有癌症，还有各种各样的健康问题。他当时躺在医院的病床上，带着氧气瓶。他告诉妻子那天早上他要开枪自杀。她说只要他不在屋子里做就行。她不想清理现场。她知道他是认真的。她在石头店里听到枪声，等了大约一个小时才打救护车电话，因为他不想被抢救。他想死。
My goodness.
我的天哪。
Yeah, it's real interesting out here.
是的，这里真的很有趣。
My dad was a bird hunter. And we had three or four milk cows. My sister and brothers, they'd milk the cows. I'd feed the horse. My dad would feed the mules. He would pass through the rooms, say, get up, boys.
我父亲是个捕鸟猎人。我们有三四头奶牛。我的姐妹和兄弟会去挤奶。我会喂马。我父亲会喂骡子。他会穿过房间说：“起来，孩子们。”
Get up, boys.
“起来，孩子们。”
And look, he wasn't going to say "get up boys" but one time. And the next time, he'd say, I thought you boys were supposed to be up. The next time, he had that broom handle. And ain't no such a thing as child abuse.
听着，他不会说第二次“起来，孩子们”。下一次，他会说：“我以为你们这些孩子应该起来了。”再下一次，他就会拿着扫帚把。根本没有所谓的虐待儿童。
The first time is when he wanted it to be done.
第一次就是他希望事情完成的时候。
And you better get out the bed, because let I'm going to tell you something. My daddy didn't play. 270 pounds of pure man.
你最好起床，因为我告诉你。我爸爸不玩虚的。270磅纯爷们。
I heard that.
我听到了。
6:00 in the morning here. Just got up. Stars are bright. I'm going to go check on the horses here and give them their feed as early as possible so that they'll have time to digest it before we head out. Hello there, boys. Hello, boys. Yeah.
这里是早上6点。刚起床。繁星明亮。我要去看看马，尽早给它们喂食，这样在我们出发前它们有时间消化。你们好，孩子们。你好，小伙子们。是的。
It's hard to imagine, now that I really think about it, how a camera crew or even a news team of writers could capture what I think is best about this trip-- the movement, the familiarity with the known, the process of the day, the challenge, the freshness, the warmth of the simplicity, the support of the people like the ones in that car that waved as they just went by, the pattern of day-by-day moving as a herd across North America. There's no way that they could capture what I really want to share.
现在仔细想想，很难想象摄制组甚至新闻记者团队如何捕捉到我认为这次旅行最美好的东西——那种移动感、对已知事物的熟悉、日常的过程、挑战、新鲜感、简单的温暖、像车里那些仅仅经过时挥手的人那样的支持，那种像兽群一样横穿北美的逐日模式。他们根本无法捕捉到我真正想分享的东西。
Beautiful, quiet night. No light except the stars. The Big Dipper shining bright and pointing out to the North Star. We made it 30 miles, so I feel really good. Glad to be with my good partners, good horses. Good.
美丽的安静夜晚。除了星星外没有光。北斗七星闪耀着明亮的光芒，指向北极星。我们走了30英里，所以我感觉非常好。很高兴和我的好搭档、好马儿在一起。好。
Coming up, The Dark Side of the Horse, in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
稍后，节目继续，《马的阴暗面》，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American . Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's program, Adventures in the Simple Life.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是《简单生活的冒险》。
We're in the middle of Act One, the story of three people traveling across country with some horses and a tape recorder-- prerequisite for getting on our show. I cannot state strongly enough how much of the 30 hours of tape they recorded is simply the three of them talking about the horses. Hours of detail about the horses' shoes and the color of their urine, and how the horses are doing. And I have to say, for city people sitting in an office in Chicago, listening to all this, it was hard to understand what it was all about. But, of course, what it was all about was the difficulty of being on the road, which is where our story resumes.
我们正在第一幕的中段，三个带马和录音机的人横穿国家的故事——这是参加我们节目的先决条件。我无法足够强烈地表达他们录制的30小时磁带中有多少仅仅是他们三个人谈论马。关于马蹄铁和马尿颜色的细节，以及马的情况，录了几个小时。我不得不说，对于坐在芝加哥办公室里的城市人来说，听这一切很难理解其中的意义。但当然，这一切都是关于在路上的艰难，而我们的故事将从那里继续。
And then we started meeting the miles and meeting the challenges and being up at 2:00 in the morning fixing equipment and getting up before daylight. Some nights, we'd sleep four hours, and we didn't go to bed refreshed. We went to bed worn out. We'd get up four hours later and start feeding and brushing horses.
然后我们开始遇到里程数和挑战，凌晨2点就在维修设备，天还没亮就起床。有些晚上，我们只睡四个小时，而且睡觉时并没有感到精神焕发。我们带着疲惫入睡。四个小时后我们又得起床喂马、刷马。
So it's pouring rain, and we're stopped by a little, metal building on the side of the road. And we pulled over and one of Mac's shoes, I noticed his back, left shoe was falling off. What in the hell are we going to do? Oh, jeez.
下着倾盆大雨，我们在路边一个金属小建筑旁停下。我靠边停车，注意到麦克的马蹄铁，它的后左蹄铁要掉了。我们要怎么办？哦，天哪。
8:30 in the morning on March-- what is today, everybody?
3月——今天是几号，各位？
15th.
15号。
15th?
15号？
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
And I feel puny. My stomach is just feeling like a burnt pancake that got stepped on by an elephant and then eaten by a roadrunner and then [BLEEP] on top of a green stinkbug that's eating its way through it. And that's how my stomach feels. I might just vomit in this microphone.
我觉得很虚弱。我的胃感觉就像一张被大象踩过，又被走鹃吃掉，然后拉在正在吃它的绿色臭虫上面的烧焦的煎饼。我的胃就是这种感觉。我可能就在这个麦克风里呕吐了。
Turning right on a dirt road. And Judson's reaching for his six shooter. What's that boy doing? Oh my gosh, we're crossing into Arkansas. Oh, my gosh.
右转上一条土路。贾德森正在去拿他的左轮手枪。那家伙在干什么？天哪，我们要进入阿肯色州了。天哪。
[YELPS AND FIRES GUN]
[尖叫并开枪]
Oh, my goodness! We made it to Arkansas! [YELPS]
天哪！我们到了阿肯色州！[尖叫]
Are we really here, or is it just a dream? I think we're about to touch Texas. And there's a big old rock there that says "Texas." Oh my gosh, it's real. We're really doing it.
我们真的到了这里吗，还是在做梦？我想我们要碰到德克萨斯了。那边有一块大岩石写着“德克萨斯”。天哪，这是真的。我们真的做到了。
[GUN FIRES]
[枪声]
Yes! [YELPS] Albert, settle down, boy. It's just a .357.
是的！[尖叫] 阿尔伯特，冷静点，伙计。那只是把.357口径手枪。
Let me ask you to explain as you're going into Arizona.
让我请你解释一下当你进入亚利桑那州时的情况。
Oh, my. Very interesting situation. Almost embarrassing. But the fact is, we had just bought a horse. And this one hadn't been handled in a very long time and had a reputation, in the few times it had been handled, of being more or less wild. And so I'm riding along, and we get to the Arizona line. Every time we get to a line, one of us-- usually Judson, my brother-- shoots off a gun, just as a celebration, reckoning that we made it to another state line.
哦，天哪。非常有趣的情况。几乎让人尴尬。但事实是，我们刚买了一匹马。这匹马很久没被驯化过，在仅有的几次接触中，它有或多或少很野的名声。所以我在骑行时，到了亚利桑那州的边界。每次我们到达州界时，我们中的一个人——通常是我弟弟贾德森——会开枪，作为一种庆祝，意味着我们到了另一个州界。
So we go through the gate, and I shut the gate, and we're there. It's like, OK, let's celebrate. And intuitively, I knew not to get up on this horse. But my brother, for some reason, I don't know why, he said, get up on your horse. And for some reason, I followed his instructions and got up on the horse.
所以我们穿过大门，我把门关上，我们就在那儿。心想，好吧，庆祝一下吧。直觉上，我知道不该骑这匹马。但我弟弟，出于某种原因，我不知道为什么，他说：“骑上你的马。”出于某种原因，我听从了他的指示，骑上了马。
There it is, boy. It's the state line. We're getting ready for a big bang. My gosh, we're getting into Arizona. Woo! We are walking in the soul of another state, and proud of it.
到了，伙计。这是州界。我们要准备一场大爆炸了。天哪，我们要进入亚利桑那州了。呜！我们正走进另一个州的灵魂，对此我感到自豪。
[SHOOTS GUN] [YELPS]
[开枪] [尖叫]
I got bucked off of this damn black horse. He's not used to a gunshot. Guess I'm trying to stay awake now. Seems like maybe my head is addled. Maybe I have a concussion or something.
我从这该死的黑马上被甩下来了。它不习惯枪声。猜我正在努力保持清醒。好像我的头可能被撞坏了。可能我有脑震荡之类的。
And I cracked my head. Blood everywhere. The power of it goes from my head to my shoulder, twisted my neck, hit my back, tearing my back open, ripping my shirt. And I'm just sitting there slumped, hurting. And it was not what I wanted to happen.
我撞破了头。到处都是血。力量从我的头传到肩膀，扭伤了脖子，撞了背，背部裂开，衬衫被扯破。我只是瘫坐在那儿，疼痛不已。这不是我想要发生的。
How much of a break did you take before you started writing again? Did you take the--
在重新开始骑行前，你休息了多久？你有……
I didn't take a minute off. I climbed back up, blood was still running down. The blood knitted my hair back together. That's what held my scalp together. I just let the dried blood hold it back together.
我一分钟都没停。我爬了回去，血还在流。血把我的头发粘在一起。这就是把我的头皮粘在一起的东西。我只是让干涸的血粘住它。
Did you think about seeing a doctor?
你有想过看医生吗？
There weren't any doctors anywhere nearby. Oh, my. My brother and Susan are kind of like normal people. But my lifestyle has been forever very extraordinarily different than common, normal America. Just about a month ago, I rode a horse into a tree. I was chasing another horse. And it got dark, and I did not want to give up on catching this horse. It was the first time I'd ever let this horse go.
附近没有任何医生。哦，天哪。我弟弟和苏珊有点像正常人。但我的生活方式永远与普通的、正常的美国极其不同。就在一个月前，我骑马撞到了一棵树。我当时在追另一匹马。天黑了，我不想放弃捕捉这匹马。这是我第一次放走这匹马。
So I ran right into a tree and knocked my head back. When I came forward, all of a sudden I heard all this splashing. Blood was flying all around my saddle splashing down. And I wondered, my gosh, what have I done? And I stuck my tongue through my lip. It was right through the front of my face. I was like, ooh, that does not feel right.
所以我直接撞到树上，头向后仰。当我向前时，突然听到泼溅声。血飞得到处都是，溅在马鞍上。我纳闷，天哪，我做了什么？我把舌头穿过嘴唇。它直接穿过了我的脸部前方。我心想，哦，那感觉不太对。
So I went to a mirror. See, I don't have electricity, so I lit some candles and looked in the mirror, and I had three huge holes in my face that were gaping open, profusely bleeding. So I could've gone to a doctor. I live way out in the country. But I just got out a needle and thread and sewed my face back together. It was about 14 stitches. Pulled it back together and I was good to go. Had to heal up and the swelling had to go down and all that, but it's healed up real good.
于是我去了镜子前。你看，我没有电，所以我点了几支蜡烛对着镜子看，我脸上三个巨大的洞张开着，大量出血。我本可以去看医生的。我住得很偏远。但我只是拿出针线，把脸缝合好了。大约有14针。拉回在一起，我就没事了。伤口愈合了，肿胀也消了，一切都很好。
But see, that's the story of my life. Me, what I'm trying to teach people and what I believe in is that you can do things yourself. You can take care of yourself. You can be responsible, and should be responsible, for yourself. I was born in normal suburbia. In fact, I guess that's one of the important things about me being able to do some of these things of living like people did a long time ago, is I went from normal suburbia. I know the American people. I can speak your language. But I live in a very different way that's come through decades of experience and voluntarily living by a whole other set of values and reality.
但你看，这就是我的生活故事。我试图教给人们的是，我相信的是，你可以自己做事情。你可以照顾自己。你可以负责，也应该为自己负责。我出生在普通的郊区。实际上，我想能够做这些很久以前人们生活方式的事，其中一个重要点是我来自普通郊区。我了解美国人民。我能说你们的语言。但我以一种完全不同的方式生活，这是经过几十年的经验，自愿选择生活在另一套价值观和现实中得来的。
Even when you embark on an adventure in the simple life, it doesn't get all that simple. Life resists simplicity. On this horse trip across America, the logistics of getting from place to place were as complicated as you might imagine, with that truck to move around and 20th century traffic always threatening to run them over. And then having to provision horses and get new horses and find a place to stay every night. It took money and telephones and all the skill with people that anybody would be able to muster.
即使你开始了简单生活的冒险，生活也不会变得那么简单。生活抵制简单。在这场骑马横穿美国的旅程中，从一个地方到达另一个地方的后勤工作和你想象的一样复杂，要移动那辆卡车，还有20世纪的交通随时威胁着要把他们撞飞。还得提供马匹的给养、更换马匹、每天晚上找住宿的地方。这需要钱、电话，以及任何人都能调动的人际交往能力。
And then there's the mundane fact that like any people on a long trip together, Eustace and Judson and Susan got on each other's nerves sometimes. When it happened, one of them would ride ahead a ways for a while, get a break from the others. And when they finally made it to California, to the shores of the Pacific Ocean, what's striking is how bittersweet it was.
还有平凡的事实：像任何一起长途旅行的人一样，尤斯塔斯、贾德森和苏珊有时会惹恼对方。当这种情况发生时，其中一个人会向前骑一段路，从其他人那里获得休息。当他们最终到达加利福尼亚，到达太平洋海岸时，令人震惊的是它是多么的苦乐参半。
That was a pretty intense day. We started riding. And that part of California is very hilly. And you'd ride up a hill and you think, we're going to look out and see the ocean. And we didn't. We rode and rode and rode before we saw the ocean. And you're just hoping and waiting for this end. It's kind of climactic, waiting for it to come up, and it never would. You'd just see more houses and more streets. It  was like, "ugh."
那天非常紧张。我们开始骑行。加州的那部分很多山。你会翻过一座山，心想，我们要看到大海了。但我们没有。我们骑啊骑，骑了很久才看到大海。你只是在希望和等待这个终点。这有点高潮，等着它出现，但它从未出现。你只会看到更多的房子和街道。感觉就像，“呃。”
Almost at the beach. I can smell it and feel it and see it in the traffic and the worry in the people faces. And it's exciting because we're almost there.
快到海滩了。我能闻到它，感觉到它，看到交通工具，还有人们脸上的担忧。这很令人兴奋，因为我们快到了。
Hey, cowboys!
嘿，牛仔！
We are cowboys. Hey, cowboys! That's what they call us here.
我们是牛仔。嘿，牛仔！那是这里的人对我们的称呼。
And finally, we saw it. And it was like, wow. It was a weird feeling. It was like, now what do we do?
最终，我们看到了它。那种感觉很奇怪。就像，现在该怎么办？
I thought it was going to be more crazy energy. It was more self-reflective energy. It was more just sitting on your horse and staring at the ocean and going, wow. It was more just, we did it. And in the hot days of Arizona, somehow, I was just going, man, if I get to that ocean, I'm going to get off and just go running, dive in the water and swim out as far as I can. And all that crazy excitement didn't happen. It was more just a silent stare.
我以为会有更疯狂的能量。那是更自我反思的能量。更多的是坐在马上盯着大海，心想，哇。更多的是，我们做到了。在亚利桑那州炎热的日子里，不知怎的，我一直在想，如果我到了那片海，我就要下马去跑步，跳进水里，尽可能远地游出去。而所有那些疯狂的兴奋并没有发生。更多的是一种沉默的凝视。
We just stood there. Just stood there looking at it, unbelieving that we had gotten there. And looking around and, is this really sand under our feet? Are those really waves there? It was like if you could just scream "wow" and let it echo for a couple of hours. Wow, wow, wow.
我们就站在那里。只是站在那里看着它，不敢相信我们真的到了。环顾四周，我们脚下真的是沙子吗？那里真的是海浪吗？就像如果你能大喊一声“哇”并让它回荡几个小时。哇，哇，哇。
What do you carry back into your everyday life from a journey like this? Eustace is back living in the woods, having learned what he said he wanted to learn about horses on the trip. Judson's a fly fishing guide in North Carolina, starting his own business doing that. And Susan's the one who set to make the biggest transition, back to modern life, indoor life. She moved to Oklahoma to be closer to her grandfather, who's been ill.
像这样的旅程能带回什么到你的日常生活中？尤斯塔斯回到树林里生活，学到了他在旅行中想学的东西。贾德森在北卡罗来纳州做飞钓向导，开始做自己的生意。苏珊则是那个做了最大转变，回到现代生活、室内生活的人。她搬到了俄克拉荷马州，为了离生病的祖父更近一些。
What's your job now? What are you doing?
你现在的工作是什么？你在做什么？
I'm an order selector at a local warehouse here. It's Associated Wholesale Grocers.
我是这里一家仓库的订单拣货员。它是联合批发杂货店。
And so what's that's like to go to a job like that after having been on the road for months?
在路上待了几个月后，去那样的工作是什么感觉？
It's pretty crazy. We work hard every day. It's a pretty labor-intensive job. And it's interesting to look at the perspectives of my fellow employees and how this is their life, and this is what they do. And I kind of see past it, and I see what I've done and that there's so much more out there.
这太疯狂了。我们每天都很努力工作。这是一份劳动密集型工作。观察同事们的视角以及这就是他们的生活，这就是他们所做的事情，很有趣。我某种程度上看穿了这一点，我看到了我所做的事，以及外面还有更多东西。
Do you find you talk about it a lot now, months later?
几个月后，你会发现经常谈论它吗？
A little bit. Not a whole lot. I'm living in Oklahoma and don't know a whole lot of people. And if I tell them that I rode my horse across country, I don't think they'd believe me. But I reflect back on it quite a bit.
一点点。不多。我住在俄克拉荷马，不认识太多人。如果我告诉他们我骑马横穿全国，我想他们不会相信我。但我会经常回顾它。
Have you told people at work?
你告诉过工作中的人们吗？
A few.
几个。
And so what do they say?
他们怎么说？
They don't believe me.
他们不相信我。
Act Two, Zen Shmen. Here's something that was written back when people rode horses because they mostly had no choice, the middle of the 19th century, a quarter century before the invention of the light bulb. Most people lived on the farm or in small towns. And yet, America was already so big and changing so fast and so unprecedented and alarming, that already, people worried that modernity and everything all that came with it was making it hard to think properly, to feel properly, to really live. Here's the reading.
第二幕，禅宗什么的。这是写在人们因为别无选择而骑马的年代，19世纪中叶，电灯泡发明前四分之一个世纪。大多数人住在农场或小镇。然而，美国已经如此庞大，变化如此之快，以前所未有的速度变化着，以至于人们已经担心现代性及其带来的一切让思考、感受和真正生活变得困难。这里是摘录。
"I went to the woods because I wished to live deliberately, to front only the essential facts of life and see if I could not learn what it had to teach, and not, when I came to die, discover that I had not lived. I did not wish to live what was not life. I wanted to live deep, to drive life into a corner and reduce it to its lowest terms. And if it proved to be mean, wanted to get to the whole and genuine meanness of it and publish its meanness to the world. Or, if it were sublime, to know it by experience and be able to give a true account of it."
“我走进森林，因为我想审慎地生活，去直面生命的基本事实，看看我是否能学到它要教给我的东西，并且在我不幸要死时，不至于发现自己从未生活过。我不想生活得不是生活。我想活得深刻，把生命逼入角落，将其还原到最低限度。如果它被证明是卑劣的，那就去看看那种彻底而纯粹的卑劣，并向世界发布它的卑劣。或者，如果它是崇高的，那就通过经验去了解它，并能给出真实的记录。”
This is Henry Thoreau from his book Walden, published in 1854. It is a clean line of heritage from this to the voluntary simplicity movement and so many other movements today, which seek to shed all the stuff that clutters our lives, fills our heads.
这是亨利·梭罗的书《瓦尔登湖》，发表于1854年。从这里到自愿简单生活运动，以及今天许多寻求摒弃 clutter（杂乱）我们生活和头脑的运动，有着清晰的遗产线。
Here's Thoreau again. "The nation is cluttered with furniture and tripped up by its own traps, ruined by luxury and heedless expense. It lives too fast. Men think that it's essential that the nation have commerce and export ice and talk through a telegraph and ride 30 miles an hour. But whether we should live like baboons or like men is a little uncertain."
再看梭罗的文字。“这个国家堆满了家具，被自己的陷阱绊倒，被奢侈和不计后果的开支毁掉了。它生活得太快了。人们认为国家拥有商业、出口冰块、通过电报交谈、以每小时30英里的速度行驶是必要的。但我们到底是该像狒狒一样生活还是像人类一样生活，这还真不确定。”
Here's my favorite passage from Thoreau. It's especially appropriate for this week-- for any week, really, in which people are obsessed with the news. What I love about it is this simultaneously provocative and completely reasonable and, at the same time from my perspective, almost totally nuts.
这是我最喜欢的梭罗片段。它对这一周特别合适——对任何一周都合适，人们沉迷于新闻。我喜欢它是因为它既挑衅又完全合理，同时从我的角度看，它几乎完全是疯话。
He writes, "I am sure that I have never read any memorable news in a newspaper. If we read of one man robbed, or murdered, or killed by accident, or one house burned, or one vessel wrecked, or one steamboat blown up, or one cow run over on the Western Railroad, or one mad dog killed, or one lot of grasshoppers in the winter, we never need read of another. One is enough. If you're acquainted with the principle, what do you care for myriad instances and applications?
他写道：“我确信我从未在报纸上读过任何值得纪念的新闻。如果我们读到一个人被抢劫、谋杀或意外死亡，或一所房子被烧毁、一艘船遇难、一艘汽船爆炸、西部铁路上一头牛被撞、一条疯狗被杀，或冬天的蚱蜢，我们永远不需要再读第二遍。一个就够了。如果你了解原则，你还在乎无数的实例和应用吗？”
"To a philosopher, all 'news,' as it's called, is gossip. And they who edit and read it are old women over their tea. Yet, not if you were greedy after this gossip. News which I seriously think a ready wit might write a twelvemonth or 12 years beforehand with sufficient accuracy.
“对哲学家来说，所有所谓的‘新闻’都是流言蜚语。那些编辑和阅读它的人就像喝茶的老太婆。然而，如果你对这种流言蜚语贪得无厌，那就另当别论了。新闻，我认真地认为，一个机智的人提前一年或12年就能以足够的准确性写出来。”
"As for Spain, for instance. If you know how to throw in Don Carlos and the Infanta, and Don Pedro and Seville and Granada, from time to time in the right proportions-- they may have changed names a little since I saw the papers-- it will be true to the letter and give us as good an idea of the exact state or ruin of things in Spain as the most succinct and lucid reports under this head in the newspapers. And as for England, almost the last significant scrap of news from that quarter was the revolution of 1649."
“以西班牙为例。如果你知道如何从时间到时间以正确的比例加入唐·卡洛斯、公主、唐·佩德罗、塞维利亚和格拉纳达——它们的名字可能在我看报纸后略有改变——那将是完全真实的，给我们对西班牙事物的确切状态或毁灭给出一个和报纸上该标题下最简洁、最清晰的报告一样好的主意。至于英国，来自那个地方几乎最后一条重要的新闻是1649年的革命。”
Well, we move on. One of the difficulties with simplifying your life is that people are complicated. So simplifying your life often means cutting yourself off from people, which can be complicated in and of itself. Ethan Watters has this story.
好吧，我们继续。简化生活的一个困难是人们很复杂。所以简化生活通常意味着切断与人的联系，这本身可能就很复杂。伊森·沃特斯有这个故事。
A couple of years ago, my best friend, Larry left his life in San Francisco to study Zen at a monastery in the mountains near Los Angeles. What made his decision so unsettling was that Larry used to be me. We lived in the same flat. We had the same friends. We were both writers. We wrote for the same magazines. For me, this life was a blessing. Larry said it was a torturous cycle of unfulfillable desire rotting him from the inside.
几年前，我最好的朋友拉里离开他在旧金山的生活，去洛杉矶附近山里的寺院学习禅宗。他决定的令人不安之处在于拉里曾经就是我。我们住在同一个公寓。我们有同样的朋友。我们都是作家。我们为同一本杂志写稿。对我来说，这种生活是一种福气。拉里说这是一种不可满足的欲望的折磨循环，从内部腐蚀着他。
Larry has now been ordained as a monk. He's even taken a new zen name, Takado. It's been two years, but I still don't fully understand how he could have rejected our life in San Francisco. Larry picks me up at the airport while on an errand run for the Zen Center.
拉里现在已被任命为和尚。他甚至给自己起了一个新的禅名，高户。已经两年了，但我仍然无法完全理解他怎么能拒绝我们在旧金山的这种生活。拉里在为禅中心办差时在机场接我。
Here's what we have to do. We have to go Home Depot and buy a lot of things that I'm not so sure about. So we'll have to figure a lot of things out in Home Depot. And then we have to find this dry cleaners place that I think is on Central or Monte Vista.
这就是我们要做的。我们要去家得宝买很多我不确定的东西。所以我们得在家得宝解决很多事。然后我们得找到这个干洗店，我想它在中央大道或蒙特维斯塔那边。
For what?
干什么？
To bring a bowing mat that somebody spilled wax on. And then we have to go to--
带回一个被人溅上蜡的跪垫。然后我们得去——
In his new life, Larry wakes up at 2:50 in the morning to make tea for the rest of the monks and students. From 3:00 AM, it's bowing, chanting, meditation, and meetings with the Japanese zen master until the afternoon. Then he's in charge of constructing a toilet building for the monastery. Then more chanting in the evening. The daily schedule ends at 9:00 at night. I have to admit that I take a bit of perverse pleasure in the fact that even though Larry has rejected the secular life, he still has to navigate Home Depot, trying to figure out which grade of sand he needs to buy.
在他的新生活中，拉里在凌晨2点50分起床，为其他和尚和学生泡茶。从凌晨3点开始，就是叩拜、诵经、冥想，以及与日本禅师的会面，直到下午。然后他负责为寺院建造一个厕所。然后晚上继续诵经。每日日程在晚上9点结束。我不得不承认，我有一种反常的快乐，因为拉里即使拒绝了世俗生活，仍然必须在家得宝寻找他需要购买的沙子等级。
30 mesh sand.
30目沙子。
I don't know that I'd use this.
我不确定我会用这个。
What would you use?
你会用什么？
The reason is that this stuff doesn't absorb water well.
原因是这东西吸水性不好。
Oh yeah?
哦，是吗？
Driving around the suburbs filling the pickup with supplies is like old times. We gossip about mutual friends, talk about this and that. But that evening in the monastery when we get together on one of his breaks, things get a little more tense. We have the same conversation we've had a dozen times. I still want him to explain what's wrong with his old life, the life we shared. Here's what he says.
开车在郊区为皮卡填满物资就像过去一样。我们聊聊共同的朋友，谈谈这个那个。但那天晚上在寺院，当我们休息时聚在一起，气氛变得有点紧张。我们进行了我们已经进行过十几遍的对话。我仍然希望他解释他的旧生活有什么问题，那个我们共同分享的生活。他说的是。
Never been content. Restless. Never been there, never really being present, never being able to give myself fully to what it was. Holding back, ambivalence.
从未满足。躁动不安。从未在那里，从未真正身在当下，从未能够完全投身于正在做的事。保留实力，矛盾心态。
Did you see that about other people in San Francisco?
你在旧金山其他人身上看到了这一点吗？
Who, you?
谁？你？
Yeah, like me. So what's the answer to my-- I mean, do you think I'm-- of course, I'm suffering, I guess. But it also seems balanced out by this remarkably joyful existence. I guess I don't see it as a torture.
是的，就像我。那么我的问题的答案是什么？——我是说，你认为我是——当然，我遭受着苦难，我想。但这也似乎被这种极其快乐的存在所平衡。我想我不认为这是一种折磨。
That's why you're still in San Francisco and I'm here, because I saw it as a torture. And it would be silly for me to try to convince you that it's torture. In a sense, I don't really want to do that. What all these masters of various traditions say is, of course, you're blind and you're living in a dream. You don't know, you don't realize how much suffering you're in.
这就是你还呆在旧金山而我在这里的原因，因为我把它看作一种折磨。我试着让你相信这是折磨是很傻的。在某种意义上，我真的不想那样做。所有这些各种传统的导师都说，当然，你是盲目的，你生活在梦中。你不知道，你没有意识到你处于多大的苦难中。
But they don't go out dragging people out of their houses and saying, well, actually you're suffering. Whatever. Through some circumstances, I found this path. I heard this message and addressed suffering that was real to me. And I moved in that direction. And I've got to go.
但他们不会去把人们从家里拖出来说，嗯，实际上你在受苦。随便啦。通过一些机缘巧合，我找到了这条路。我听到了这个信息并解决了对我来说真实存在的苦难。我朝着那个方向前进。我得走了。
My visit is a burden for him. He's fitting it in during short breaks between chores and meditation. I'm cutting into his five hours of sleep. I follow as he goes to hit this big ceremonial piece of wood which signals the end of the day for the monastery. After he's finished whacking the wood, Larry and I climb up the hill behind the monastery.
我的来访对他来说是一种负担。他在杂务和冥想之间的短暂休息中挤出时间。我打断了他的五个小时睡眠。我跟着他去敲那块巨大的仪式性木板，那标志着寺院一天的结束。敲完木板后，拉里和我爬上了寺院后面的小山。
Hey, this is nice. Wow.
嘿，这不错。哇。
We've got a view and  nobody sees it.
我们有一个视野，没人能看到。
What's that?
那是什么？
Right down there?
就在下面？
Yeah.
是的。
That's the sea of, you know, the LA sprawl. It's pretty huge.
那是LA扩张的海。它相当巨大。
We sit down and talk.
我们坐下来交谈。
I want to know what you missed about San Francisco when you first came here and what you miss now about it or whether that's changed or whether those things have dissipated. What did you miss about San Francisco when you first came?
我想知道你刚来这里时错过了旧金山的什么，你现在错过了什么，或者这是否改变了，或者那些东西是否已经消散。你刚来时错过了旧金山的什么？
I didn't miss anything. I mean, I missed my friends. That's all.
我不错过任何东西。我是说，我错过了我的朋友。就这样。
When you say "my friends, that's all," it seems like you're being sort of-- I guess, maybe, I took that as slightly dismissive of that. That's all. To leave your friends is a thing that I couldn't, right now, do.
当你说明明说“我的朋友，仅此而已”，看起来你有点——我想，也许我把它当作对那件事的轻描淡写。仅此而已。离开你的朋友是我现在无法做到的事。
Well, to make a possibly interesting situation truthful and boring, I did it in phases. I came here for three months. When I first came back here, I thought, God, I hate this place so much. I remember that I hated-- I hate this life. It's hard. It's cold. I'm tired. I don't like to get up. It's mind numbing sitting in this box. My knees hurt. I'm bored out of my skull. I'm going to leave pretty soon. That's what I thought.
嗯，为了让一个可能有趣的情况变得真实和无聊，我是分阶段做的。我来这里待了三个月。当我刚回到这里时，我想，天哪，我太讨厌这个地方了。我记得我很讨厌——我讨厌这种生活。它很辛苦。它很冷。我很累。我不喜欢起床。坐在这个盒子里让人麻木。我的膝盖疼。我无聊透顶。我很快就要走了。这就是我的想法。
But I said, well, it's kind of embarrassing to go running back, so I'll hang. For the wrong reason that works the right way, I stayed. And then in time, things unfolded, and they were so powerful. And they brought me crying to my knees enough times, and I felt like the years that I had been traveling around the world and seeing all these things had felt like I was traveling around the world in an iron lung. And here I was given the opportunity to get out of the iron lung and live in this simple place in the mountains.
但我说，嗯，跑回去有点尴尬，所以我再呆一会儿。出于错误的原因而以正确的方式工作，我留下了。然后随着时间的推移，事情展开了，它们太强大了。它们让我无数次哭着跪下，我觉得我多年来一直在世界各地旅行，看到所有这些东西，就像在铁肺里环游世界。而在这里，我有机会走出铁肺，住在这个山里简单的地方。
I still miss you, I have to say.
我不得不说，我仍然想你。
I wish that my friends could experience what I've experienced. And the world is a thousand times more interesting to me now than it was.
我希望我的朋友能体验我所体验过的。世界对我来说比以前有趣了一千倍。
Have you discovered in all this why you are so tortured-- I mean, why you are more tortured than, say, me? Although you claim to know that I'm tortured as well. But you have to believe me.
你从这一切中发现为什么你如此受折磨吗？——我是说，为什么你比我更受折磨？虽然你声称知道我也在受折磨。但你必须相信我。
When I see you, many times I see you as a portrait of torture. Your posture and your eyes looking away. And I can ask a few strategic, simple questions if I were to be sadistic about it and want to see this state of writhing. I can see you writhe in the way your eyes dart and the distraction of you.
当我看到你时，很多时候我把你视为折磨的肖像。你的姿势和你的眼神在回避。如果我想残忍点，想看到这种扭动的状态，我可以问几个策略性的、简单的问题。我能看到你的眼睛闪烁，你的分心。
Like what questions? What are we talking about?
什么问题？我们在说什么？
How's things going with your girlfriend? That could be a question I could have asked any time in the last five years and seen you do the dance of writhing. You're writhing now. I ask you this question and you're writhing now. You're not writhing because of the question entirely. You're writhing because it points to a deep sore spot in your soul.
你女朋友最近怎么样？这可能是我过去五年里任何时候都可以问的问题，看你跳出那种扭动的舞蹈。你现在正在扭动。我问你这个问题，你现在正在扭动。你不是完全因为问题而扭动。你扭动是因为它指向你灵魂深处的一个隐痛。
The problem with this discussion is that we disagree on all the premises. Larry doesn't see any value in his old life, the life I'm still leading. He thinks I'm barely experiencing the world. I have the same doubts about his life. He says he's never felt more alive, but I see his move to the simple life of the monastery as a withdrawl from the world. It would be easier to be more accepting of his choice if he could be more accepting of my world view.
这个讨论的问题在于我们在所有前提上都不同意。拉里看不到他的旧生活、我仍然过着的那种生活有什么价值。他认为我几乎没有体验过世界。我对他的生活有同样的怀疑。他说他从未感到如此活着，但我认为他搬到寺院的简单生活是对世界的逃避。如果他能更接受我的世界观，我也更容易接受他的选择。
The fact is, Larry tried to simplify and clarify his life by coming here. But his life refused to be simplified. Shortly after he arrived at Mt. Baldy, he met a charming zen student named Katherine. Love affairs are discouraged at Mt. Baldy, so for over a year, Larry and Katherine had a mattress in the woods, and they would sneak away when they could.
事实是，拉里试图通过来这里来简化和澄清他的生活。但他的生活拒绝被简化。他到达巴尔迪山后不久，遇到了一个迷人的禅学生凯瑟琳。巴尔迪山不鼓励婚外情，所以一年多来，拉里和凯瑟琳在树林里有一张床垫，他们能偷偷溜走时就去那里。
When Larry decided that he couldn't fulfill his monk duties, study zen, and have a relationship with Katherine, she left the monastery. Larry's now decided that in a few months, after the toilet building is finished, he'll follow her. I feel vindicated that he's leaving. I'm not proud of that.
当拉里决定他无法履行和尚职责、研究禅宗，同时又与凯瑟琳谈恋爱时，她离开了寺院。拉里现在决定，几个月后，等厕所大楼建好，他会跟随她。我觉得他要走证明了我当初是对的。我对此并不感到骄傲。
Is it a possibility that you'd come back to San Francisco?
你有可能回到旧金山吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Does it feel like a step back now?
现在感觉像退了一步吗？
Maybe it does. I don't know. Maybe it feels like a part of my life-- it's going to sound pompous to say I moved beyond it, but it's just suffused with things that I don't really want to pursue.
也许是吧。我不知道。也许这感觉像是我生活的一部分——说我超越了它听起来会很自大，但它只是充满了我不真的想去追求的东西。
So Larry and Katherine are going looking for another Zen community, a place that accepts couples.
所以拉里和凯瑟琳要去找另一个禅宗社区，一个接受情侣的地方。
Before I leave, I ask Larry to play some of his songs. Again, it's an experience where we disagree on every premise. I miss the times our friends would gather to hear him sing. I think it's a crime that he stopped writing his songs. Larry sees it differently. He calls them a catalog of his torture. But I make him sing a few for me. I want to get them on tape. Messages from the old Larry, a person I miss more than he does.
在我离开前，我让拉里唱几首他的歌。再次，这是一种我们在每个前提上都不同意的经历。我想念我们的朋友聚集在一起听他唱歌的日子。我觉得他停止写歌是一种罪过。拉里看法不同。他称这些为他的折磨目录。但我让他为我唱了几首。我想把它们录在磁带上。来自旧拉里的信息，一个我比他更想念的人。
[SINGING] Leave me alone. Leave me blue. Leave me, because I can't bear to leave you. Say goodnight. Hang up the phone. Believe me, when you leave me, you will leave me alone.
[唱歌] 让我一个人待着。让我忧郁。离开我，因为我无法忍受离开你。道晚安。挂断电话。相信我，当你离开我，你将让我孤独一人。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett and [? Sini ?] Davenport.
今天我们的节目由艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德参与，高级编辑保罗·塔夫，特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自劳拉·道格特和[？辛妮·达文波特？]。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
In other program notes, with this program, Paul Tough leaves his job as our senior editor to move back to Canada where he's going to run a big magazine called Saturday Night. Partly, the idea of the magazine, the name of it, comes from the very Canadian idea that on Saturday night, you stay home and you read a magazine. We'll miss Paul. Paul should still show up here on our program from time to time.
节目其他事项，随着本节目，保罗·塔夫辞去我们的高级编辑工作，搬回加拿大，在那里他将运营一本名为《星期六之夜》的大杂志。某种程度上，这本杂志的想法，它的名字，来自于一个非常加拿大的想法：在星期六晚上，你呆在家里，阅读一本杂志。我们会想念保罗。保罗偶尔还是会出现在我们的节目中。
If you want to buy a cassette of this or any of our radio programs, you can call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . Or you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet, www.thislife.org. That's thislife, one word, no space. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who does our website.
如果你想购买本节目或我们任何广播节目的磁带，你可以拨打我们芝加哥WBEZ的电话，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址，[email protected]。或者你可以在互联网上免费收听我们大部分的节目，www.thislife.org。也就是thislife，一个词，没有空格。感谢为我们制作网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。
Eustace Conway, the guy who led the trip across the country on a horse, has his own website. You know, this is just how far the internet has gone. People who live without electricity have their own websites. That address, members.aol.com/tipreserve. Or you could just get there from our site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
尤斯塔斯·康威，那个骑马横穿全国的人，有他自己的网站。你知道，互联网发展到什么程度了。那些不通电的人都有自己的网站。那个网址是 members.aol.com/tipreserve。或者你可以直接从我们的网站进去。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who describes management oversight this way--
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他这样描述管理监督——
Tortuous cycle of unfulfillable desire rotting him from the inside.
不可满足的欲望的折磨循环，从内部腐蚀着他。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
Many times, I see you as a portrait of torture.
很多时候，我看到你就像折磨的肖像。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。